or we should be looking for ray after he
told us not to what the hell are you
doing here ditto I thought you said
they'd be psyched to see us
look I know you've been thinking but if
you just let me explain if you're here
to apologize for boggling the bureau and
and and humiliating Gary well we
actually did that for a good reason
because we have to stop Moloch Mallis
and yes we know all about him Sarah
basically met him and you're here
because the time bureau has finally come
to its senses or Ava and I are working
together independently right Wally it's
good to see you
I remember you from Barry and iris is
wedding yeah wasn't that so fun it was
such a beautiful ceremony if your orders
were like met and then the Nazi invasion
the well alright you guys still haven't
told us why you're on the ship atoning I
hope I should never have kept you both
in the dark the deaths of those agents
and the return of damian darhk-- will
haunt me for the rest of my days but
surely you understand the gravity now of
what we're facing hey what are you doing
here amen oh man what the hell are you
doing here you me sign of Ray no just
another Grateful Dead and I first sure
got a contact I yeah my manners to swipe
Jerry Garcia's glasses oh what's the
thief oh is if he mmm no we we allowed
light to moderate theft on the show we
like to call me sweet veneers
[Music]
it's okay work work more come on the
stupid thing work a stupid thing has
been in my family for generations it
should have been mine well it's mine now
besides Wallace wishes for only his most
devoted followers to wield totems and
you already have one now why can't I
access its powers because power is all
it is to you until you find a selfless
reason to wield it
my grandmother's bond to the totem even
at a distance will remain stronger than
yours what about this fire totem I stole
in Detroit afraid of a broken trinket
nothing killed me once even in pieces
it's still to be feared totems are
eternal they can never be destroyed so
they can be fixed
oh so I get a necklace myself yeah but
take a truly brilliant mind to figure
out how you guys hungry
I just really go for some eggs poached
runny
oh my coffee the grass-fed butter MCT
oil couple questions why do I look like
I just woke up because I did why am I
wearing a beret well because I can three
why am I take you over today because I
want to I'm out in San Diego reason
being because we wrapped last week we
wrapped on legends and everyone's
dispersed and and gone to their their
little their little getaways for a
little bit I went to a music festival
went and danced which is really fun
hence the Brahe and I'm gonna be sharing
some cool moments from the past from
filming with the guys I was so lucky to
join this cost and be welcomed by
everyone with open arms and I hope I can
give you a little insight into the fun
that we had over time I hope you guys
enjoy it
everybody it's Charlie Wally West is
finally on the Waverider let's break
this down so if you guys didn't know
wally west is gonna be around for the
rest of the season like kenyan Lonsdale
was saying that i'm gonna show you a
little bit of behind the scenes stuff
they officially wrapped the final
episode everybody went on bake
last week so that's like episode 18 what
they'll do is I don't know if there's
gonna be any more breaks in the season
but they'll air all the rest of the
Legends episodes then Supergirl comes
back to that Monday night slot so if
you're wondering where that went legends
is gonna air the rest of its episodes
then Supergirl comes back but flash
Black Lightning arrow they all stay on
the same day in tomorrow is our flash
family episode two so there's a lot of
big flashed up happening on Mondays and
Tuesdays for the rest of the season if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a flash ring giveaway that's
going on so Wally walks on makes fun of
mullis's name they just take shots at
everybody on this TV show mollusc no
malice a little bit of awkwardness
between Sarah and Ava I don't know how
they're gonna drag that out or how big
the storyline is gonna be because there
was a marriage on arrow and the flash
but neither one of the shows has spent a
whole lot of time referencing it I think
on the Barry iris side of that it'll be
a little more relevant when we get into
more coffee shop girl backstory she'll
be back in future episodes and I did
learn a couple future episode titles but
we can talk about that more during my
flash video tomorrow they remind you
that heat wave is one of the flash
rogues like Wally just yoinks Jerry
Garcia is a glasses away from him no no
no we allow petty theft which I love
like oh we call them souvenirs here just
pinching stuff here and there no big
deal but the Legion of Doom has the fire
totem they basically give you an
explainer for some of the mythology
behind it you can't destroy them and
they can be used to kill other people
for what you did to my village
[Music]
so like the fire totem is very deadly
for kuwasa kuwasa hates the out of
Nora dark I think it gives you a pretty
clear foreshadowing for their arc this
season like they're probably gonna eat
themselves alive before the legends
defeat them they foreshadow a little bit
that Ray might be forced to help them
reform the totem because they say only a
brilliant mind could do it that he
suddenly wakes up spouting all this
Paleo diet stuff there's this weird meta
thing going on because in real life
Brandon Ralph is almost like a
spokesperson for bulletproof coffee
which is all part of this Paleo diet
lifestyle the whole thing about Nora not
being able to tap into the power of the
spirit totem because a Maya's connection
is so much stronger with it is actually
kind of a Voltron thing if you haven't
been watching the Voltron animated
series on Netflix there's a special
connection that each of the pilots have
with the Lions that extends across
space-time so that if someone tries to
take your lion if your connection with
it is deeper and more fundamental then
they won't be able to activate it so
it's sort of like this security measure
so we have an aura dark arc in
present-day but also reminder that
Cortney the actress that plays that
character is married to Brandon Roth in
real life so this has really meta thing
going on with husband and wife on screen
so it'll be fun to watch them play off
of each other because I don't know that
they've actually acted on-screen
together a whole lot but just post all
your questions in the comments below
that you want me to include in my
episode video later tonight so obviously
that'll post after the episode goes up
flash family episode tomorrow with Jay
Garrick and Jesse quick and then Roy is
back on arrow on Thursday night so like
really big DC TV stuff happening this
week if you're a big fan of Jessica
Jones all the Jessica Jones episodes are
actually dropping on Wednesday at
midnight not on Thursday because the
series is premiering one day early
because Thursday is like International
Women's Day so they're trying to do some
special launch thing so we'll talk about
Jessica Jones in separate videos DC TV
in DC TV videos but only in the giveaway
winner when I post my legends video
later tonight so click here for brand
new flash and click here for brand new
Avengers infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight